[Music]
at protest after protest in the United
States in recent years activists have
insisted they won't be Fooled Again
many thought they'd seen progress now
the Fatal police beating of Tyree
Nichols in Memphis has many questioning
whether they've made any Headway at all
in stopping police brutality against
African Americans I thought this was
over with after George Floyd I really
did as the head of black lives matter in
Lake County Illinois Clyde McLemore no
wide-eyed Optimist had found New Hope in
recent years but one incident after
another has dashed them the state of
policing has not changed since
Jim Crow
uh
this is uh it wasn't about
seven black police officers it was about
policing in this country
each incident Bears the name of a black
victim from the deadly police choking of
George Floyd in Minneapolis to the
crippling shots fired into the back of a
surviving Jacob Blake in Kenosha
Wisconsin the Memphis assault was so
ferocious it reminded many of the brutal
1991 Los Angeles police beating of
Rodney King also captured on video since
then police have grown more militarized
but they're also more monitored there's
been progress in holding police
accountable for misbehavior
through
technologies that record what they do at
the scene there has not been progress on
the street toward repairing the
fractured relationship between black
urban America and police officers
last year police killed nearly 1200
people in the U.S according to the
nonprofit group mapping police violence
more than in any year in the past decade
and black Americans made up 26 percent
of them though they make up just 13
percent of the population
across the country it's not just
communities that are demoralized it's
also the police themselves here in
Chicago over the past year they've upped
recruitment efforts bringing in 950 new
officers but that's still well short of
the 1000 and more who've left
once again in Chicago New York Los
Angeles and now in Memphis across the
U.S demonstrators are lamenting the
death of another black man at the hands
of police
[Music]
and reevaluating the state of civil
rights in America John hendron Al
Jazeera Chicago